[Music]
you want your kids to be in show
business or would you like them because
a lot of people myself included I don't
want my kids anywhere in New York show
business I want them to like sell
linoleum or some you know I kind of want
some of that Maile money I mean Billy
Ray did it he was like you know I'm
getting them to work their tongue act
I'm giving them phone figures I'm
teaching them at its work and
ill-fitting outfits I'm like work that
girls work it come on someday be mas
we're gonna make some big money come on
girls back to one back to one let's do
this again
converts worst dad ever and the results
are in and your yes your worst dad ever
girl is gotta be worried you're white no
no your wife of six years the beautiful
Rebecca Romijn what I obsessed with for
years to deck her ears she I found that
the last time she was on the show we're
talking and is she just revealed that
she never changed her name right she
never became Rebecca Romijn
Oh Carl O'Connell right well I mean
listen I look I was a fan of my wife's
when my wife was Rebecca Romijn my wife
was a pretty famous swimsuit model it
would be gross if my wife took my name I
mean I'm like I would be grossed out by
that I only know where is Rebecca Romijn
I'm a fan first husband second I mean
even the thought of it I wouldn't take
O'Connell I was thinking about actually
taking Romain Jerry O'Connell well me
Romain is a much cooler last name Brian
or O'Connell they're just so my wife's
made name is much cooler than my name I
should have taken her name uh you know
this is 2013 maybe things are changing
all kinds of things are changing with
marriage who knows
take it Conan I dare you I know a lawyer
over on Ventura he can make it happen
right next to the park really yeah all
right I'm gonna do it no I I find that
to be a fascinating thing that you
didn't so you know wasn't even a
discussion with you guys whether we do
it or whether we not do it oh no I not
at all we're really I
it's not time it's why why right why
it's old-fashioned who needs that I
think it is yeah yeah all right I want
to ask you about you play on the show
you play an ob/gyn yes or as I refer to
it as a lady doctor lady doctor lady
doctor yeah because sometimes I mess up
the letters so I just say lady doctor
makes me
that must that must inspire a lot of
confidence in your patient well obg I
don't know well it's sort of difficult
you can't really do research for it you
can't say to an a lady doctor you know
is it okay if I tag along
you know it's not like if you're gonna
play a cop and you ride around with a
cop right I mean you can't do that with
an OBGYN yeah you can't be like oh you
know I'm an actor and I'm gonna be here
well yeah a woman with her legs up in
the stirrups is that Jerry O'Connell no
it's Jerry romaine these are private
moments there's there's no way I could
do research for this role like you know
like Daniel day-lewis would you know
yeah do you think you would make I mean
you've played the role do you think you
would make it a good lady doctor um no I
would not you know I I have dealt with
lady doctors in the past my wife had
children and you deal with them like yes
and all that stuff and it was uh you
know I was in the room when my kids were
born and it was a stressful time I was
not doing well all I remember is the
anesthesiologist who's there you know
medicating your wife who was doing all
the work
leaning over to me and going hey man are
you gonna be okay I guess you know you
wear that germ thing and I was breathing
in and out very heavily it was uh you
know I was I thought in the old day was
like old movies where like dad's like
paste in the hallway and smoke cigars
and then a nurse came out and said
whether it's a girl or a boy you know I
I know for a fact that my dad wasn't in
the room at all no he was near the
hospital I don't even know he was in the
same country we know but we know what he
was wearing
yeah that's what things like you know
right
but it is that old Ricky Lucy another
Lucy show where like Ricky is in the
club doing his job and they come in and
go what's up but you know it's a boy
take eyes for everybody that's know now
they've got us in there taking the baby
out yeah Amy I say hey if I'm pulling
the baby out um one of my friends said
did you take pictures and I was like
hell to the now like barely conscious